why do you want to tell this story like
you have this star wars-esque space romp
why do you want to tell it and if they
don't have a good answer
how does a writer give story meaning
it probably comes down to theme and
making us root for the main character
for the protagonist or care for the
characters in general
theme is absolutely crucial that you
define that theme as early on as
possible in your foundational elements
it's the why are you writing this why is
it relevant why is it urgent what is
this story about what is it
communicating
so if that is something that is
compelling and pure and
um
relevant to our times
and you're showing it not telling us and
you're not preaching a message but
you're just showing drama that explores
that theme
then I think you have a really good
chance of giving your story meaning
do we always have to like the main
character we don't always have to but
that's probably a good example uh
if we don't like the main character if
they're an anti-hero there needs to be
some meaning to the story there needs to
be a reason for it to exist you know
or there's other characters that we
really care about you know like in
Breaking Bad Walt just keeps getting
worse and worse he's turning into this
monster but we do care about the
surrounding characters too you know
I think you've said to create surprising
stories how does a writer do this
uh that's kind of the magic sauce is
um
how can you hit that signpost beat in
the correct page range
and yet still surprise us still pull the
rug out from under us
um I mean it's kind of writing writing
should surprise you as The Story Goes On
you know good writing should surprise
you should
um not be predictable
so I mean I think just the trick is ask
yourself
uh could the reader see this coming you
know is this predictable and then that's
why you want to show it to friends you
show it to three friends and every one
of them says okay I kind of saw that
midpoint coming you know that twist
where the house burns down and you're
like okay well I need to hide the build
up to the house burning down you know or
maybe the house doesn't burn down maybe
there's some other disaster that happens
at the midpoint um
but that's kind of good writing is you
have to figure out how to surprise the
reader
and is that something that's it's almost
like chemistry between two people you
can't really Define why it happens but
it happens it's magic is that is that
the part of the writing process that is
not really definable not teachable in
some sense
pretty much I mean that I think that's
kind of maybe
the the number one thing is you can't
teach someone how to come up with
surprising compelling
uh
story elements you know plot points
Beats
you can't uh that can't really be taught
I think it just has to be
in your nature that maybe it's that you
have to have that intention because a
lot of new writers
their intention is just to write
something that's commercial and that can
sell and so they're like oh I'm just
going to write something like X TV show
or x movie
but as you go on
and you get better and better you
realize I need to surprise that reader
and yeah I mean I can I push my writers
and my students to you know when I saw
this coming come up with a more
surprising beat there
and sometimes it takes two or three
passes before they do but I I do see
them making that progress
but there are those writers that it just
kind of never clicks for them you know
they're they're trying to string
together cliches
rather than they don't have that fire in
them to tell a unique story
well I like what you said earlier about
pouring it into this mold and I think
that's a great analogy but if we broke
it down again to dating it's like oh
I've got this great gal you can she's
wonderful we'll you know we'll set up
this meeting and the chemistry isn't
there and you can go on all these dates
and it's not there but then you run into
the right one and it is and you can't
explain why that is you can make
yourself ready same thing with the story
you can you can figure out all these
things I I mean there's the in
indefinable X Factor what makes a story
a character a scene compelling and
amazing and exciting
there is an X Factor that can't be
taught you know
um
but I can teach you
techniques that are going to get you
further and further toward writing
something really compelling I can also
the first step is
uh writer comes to me and I say give me
free log lines for three separate
Concepts three separate ideas so maybe
one movie and two series
and I'll tell them what jumps out at me
and I'll ask them a bunch of questions
you know like maybe
um I have a I have a writer who
he just has this dream he wants to write
like a big
um police procedural story or like a
Navy Seals action thing
but his other ideas are better so we've
been working on these other ideas you
know like he has something set in the
tech world and because he works in the
tech world and he lives in the Bay Area
and he knows that so much better but
he's never been a Navy SEAL he's never
been a cop
and so
you know every now and then I say well
okay
we're working on this script we've been
working on this a long time what about
your next one hit me with some more log
lines
and his other his ideas that aren't
action and cliche the ones that are
about people and family and interesting
settings and culture he's also Asian and
so I said work Asian culture into your
stories as well you know and I kind of
had to push him in that direction it
wasn't natural for him but then when he
started to do it it really jumped out
and I said you know maybe you should
explore that idea and that turned out to
be a good thing that's a great story
yeah almost as if uh you know people
like the concept of something or the
idea of something like a career but
maybe they're not totally suited for it
I don't know if it's the same with story
um I think it's the same with the topic
they chew topic and genre they choose so
like I've had Writers come to me and
like they love Sci-Fi movies and they
really want to write a sci-fi movie but
they might not be the best person to
write a sci-fi movie they may end up
writing a story about their family and
when they grew up
but that'll take a while and it'll take
at least you know a few weeks or a month
of talking with them and having Zoom
sessions and just asking them like why
do you want to tell this story like you
have this star wars-esque uh space romp
why do you want to tell it and if they
don't have a good answer
you know if it's just I just like those
movies well that's not a good enough
answer to spend so much time hundreds of
hours on something and then risk the
rejection when you submit it and have to
rewrite it for for many drafts you know
it's a lot of work and there is a lot of
rejection involved and you have to be
able to put up with that and so why
do that why commit that time and effort
and toil to a story that you don't
really care about